customizable dashboards the general
availability of ibm cloud pack for
multi-cloud management version 2.0
and an introduction to ibm cloud for
vmware regulated workloads
all on this episode of ibm cloud now hey
everyone i'm
ian and i'm excited to be back bringing
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements
from ibm cloud to kick off this episode
i wanted to share a bunch of new
enhancements to the ibm cloud dashboard
now instead of having only one default
dashboard and layout
you can create and customize unlimited
dashboards
add widgets arrange the layout just how
you want it save the dashboard
and then easily share it with other
users in your account
if you're not sure where to start take
advantage of one of our dashboard
templates
it's a great way to begin customizing
your landing experience
you can also utilize the scope dashboard
functionality to only display the
resources that are relevant to you and
your team
go back and update the scope whenever
your needs change
now creating and sharing unlimited
dashboards may seem overwhelming but
there's no need to stress out
we have created an experience to help
manage any dashboard you create or
that's been shared with you
to get started with these great new
features on the ibm cloud dashboard
check out the link i've got in the
description below
next up we've got the general
availability of ibm cloud pack for
multi-cloud management version 2.0
there are a number of great new features
in this release including additional
self-service capabilities
this allows developers to provision
infrastructure and application
components from a pre-defined service
flow
we're also offering enhanced sre tools
for hybrid applications
including bastion control session replay
and chat ops
additionally there have been updates to
governance risk and compliance policies
to allow for a faster
more flexible solution for both vms and
containers
and we're even introducing an
operator-based way to install the cloud
pack
22 operators support the cloud pack in
both go and helm
allowing for multiple install options to
learn more about all the features in
this release
click the link below finally i want to
close out this episode by talking a
little about ibm cloud for vmware
regulated workloads
it's a part of the ibm cloud for
financial services solution set
and utilizes its policy framework which
deploys a shared responsibility model
for implementing controls
ibm cloud for vmware regulated workloads
is a secure
automated reference architecture that
enhances vmware vcenter server on ibm
cloud
this delivers a security rich high
performance platform for vm workloads
in regulated industries with this
solution
you'll be able to more effectively
implement and govern security controls
in the cloud
ensure auditing of all cloud
administration help protect business
critical data assets
and prioritize meeting it compliance to
learn more about the reference
architecture and the key attributes of
ibm cloud for vmware regulated workloads
see the link below thanks for joining me
today for this episode of ibm cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and of course please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now